[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 20th of
October I'm Kate Andrews the spectator's
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show
the Prime Minister has resigned at 1 30
PM this afternoon Liz trust took to the
steps of Downing Street where she
announced that she was resigning from
her position as leader of the
conservative party we are expected to
have a new prime minister by the end of
next week in order to give you rapid
analysis we did a special episode of
spectator TV earlier today with our
politics team to give you all the
details and you can watch that through
the link up on your screen here but I
was also joined by Andrew Neal earlier
today to talk about the future of the
conservative party
Joe Biden has brought in strict export
control rules for the microchip industry
what does this mean for tensions with
China Carrie Brown and Ann Williams will
join me
over in the United States the midterms
are just a few weeks away as we approach
polling day who's ahead I'll speak to
Freddie gray and Stephanie Brown James
Matt Ridley writes in this week's
magazine that a new strain of bird flu
could devastate Britain's Wildlife he'll
be on to explain
and finally who are just stop oil the
group who threw tomato soup over Van
Gogh sunflowers I'll speak to Emma Brown
a spokesperson for the group
this episode is sponsored by canacore
genuity wealth management experience
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support in
challenging times visit kenduwealth.com
for more information
and why not subscribe to our YouTube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
the prime minister is gone but one could
argue that her agenda started to
diminish weeks before she announced her
resignation Andrew Neil joins me now to
talk about what all this means for the
conservative party
Angie the whole world has been watching
what's been going on in the UK what do
you make of it all the world is watching
and it's shaking its head in disbelief
and
uh there's in a few short weeks this
government has managed to trash
Britain's International reputation and
it will take a long time to recover uh
from it I mean the the Liz truss
Premiership is over
uh all the measures that she stood for
have now been reversed she doesn't have
a home secretary that she wanted she's
another Chancellor that she or wanted
there is chaos in the Parliamentary
party and all that remains to happen now
is for conservative MP is to find a way
of getting rid of her as soon as
possible and then more difficultly to
find a candidate around which they can
rally because for all the talk of the
units you can it isn't clear that there
is a unit energy at the moment and if
the Tories want to grow up
they will have to swallow their
differences and rally around someone who
may not be ideal uh from their point of
view but we've seen the consequences of
voting ideologically you end up with a
no-nothing prime minister who has uh
done things to the country which are
inconceivable in weeks before and maybe
they'll have to settle for someone like
Rishi sunak who doesn't take all their
ideological boxes but his competence
knowledge and above all we'll have the
confidence of the markets we shall see
Victoria parties growing up enough to do
that maybe there's a headless chicken
now it can't help itself Andrew the
winter that we have coming up is going
to be one of the most difficult that
many people will have experienced so far
the NHS waiting list is at 7 million and
Counting energy bills are going to be at
least double what they were last year
even with the subsidies in place there's
talk of blackouts and shortages
hopefully that's the worst case scenario
but people are having to prepare for
these realities it makes complete sense
that the public want just basic levels
of stability and competence is this
going to be the real problem for the
conservative party that in the medium
term this is what people remember oh
what is what forget what's up happened
you can't trash a country's reputation
you can't trash A party's reputation for
economic confidence and expect people to
forget that quickly uh they didn't
forget it in 1992 after black Wednesday
when John Major was forced to leave the
European exchange rate mechanism even
five years later they haven't forgotten
it and Tony where Blair won by a record
Landslide majority of the Tories were
out for almost a generation so they're
not going to forget it and they're
particularly not going to affect it
because we're heading for a pretty Grim
winter on a number of fronts that you
have outlined the problem with the trust
government to be honest with Liz trust
herself is that she has no authority to
deal with any of that she has no
authority to deal with strikes she has
no authority to deal with the nurses
going out on strike or voting to go on
strike she has no authority to try and
keep payorizes below the level of
inflation she has no authority to deal
with International matters that she has
no authority to deal with anything at
all there is no purpose
to a list trust government anymore it
doesn't stand for what she stands for is
increasingly not populated by people
that she wanted in the first place it
doesn't get the Tories any votes she is
a major political embarrassment just
look at the opinion polls and you see
how far the tour is on behind that is
probably unrecoverable maybe the most
the tourists can hope for is the
difference between losing badly and a
Wipeout uh but the longer they allow
this to go on because they can't make up
their minds the more damage it will be
done the country is finished with this
trust that's gone that's history that
can't be put back in its box oh we're
waiting for is for the Tory party to
catch up with the rest of the country
and Andrew I just wanted to pick you up
on that point about economic competence
there because a lot of people point to
the mini budget and the fact that there
is lots of borrowing announced and
absolutely no talk of fiscal restraint
no lip service paid to fiscal discipline
as the moment in which the trust
Premiership started to come to an end
would you put the same date on it or did
you see signs of how this would go
earlier in her Premiership perhaps even
during the leadership campaign
there were clear signs during the
leadership campaign that law would
protracted to leadership campaign that
that she was on Major matters of State
she was out of her death and that
particularly when it came to the economy
she didn't really know what she was
talking about I remember her talking
about monetary policy and what there is
to learn from the bank of Japan so it
was complete nonsense and irrelevant and
the markets would have clocked that the
markets would have clocked that they had
somebody here who was out of a depth and
didn't know what she was talking about
then comes the mini budget and that was
the Constance of Ally of everything
because there were certain things that
could have been done which would have
been barely a ripple in the market since
she had stuck with some kind of energy
price guarantee that would have been
fine every major economy from Germany
downwards is doing that she promised to
get rid of National Insurance the
National Insurance rise the markets had
priced that in they knew they were happy
the corporation tax was not going to be
increased but on a wave of ideological
fervor not realizing that the weather
had changed and that you couldn't borrow
any more vast amounts of money for next
to nothing they went on and added a
whole more another slew of unfunded uh
tax cuts too and the markets then said
no this is over now this is uh too much
you can't do this you don't have cart
launch just to borrow Willie Nelly and
the consequence of that of taking this
wrong turn
is that a fiscal position for Britain
that would have been acceptable to the
markets a month ago or two months ago or
three months ago given our Behavior
given the trust government's Behavior
over the past month is no longer
acceptable example the bar is much
higher we will have to do more look at
what ads had to do with the uh 1p cut in
income tax not only is that not not
going to happen in April because there
was no need for it in April anyway it's
not going to even happen in April of
2024 when Rishi sunak had promised it uh
we are now heading we've already got the
highest tax burden uh for 70 years it's
about to get higher now the markets are
demanding it we can't borrow as much the
markets are now going to subject us to a
higher standard than they would have
done before this clone car arrived in
time
Joe Biden has targeted China's microchip
industry new restrictions brought in
over the weekend mean every American
Executive and engineer working in
China's semiconductor industry now risks
losing their citizenship if they don't
resign and Williams writes about it for
The Spectator website this week and he
joins me now alongside Carrie Brown
author of XI a study in power
and you write for the spectator's
website this week that the chip war
between China and America has been
intensifying can you tell us more about
what exactly that war is over and what's
been happening
well this is over Supremacy in the
production of of microchip
semiconductors uh where the United
States is trying to restrict China's
access to the most high powered chips
now China for its part is desperately
trying to catch up with the West with
Taiwan in the production of chips and is
throwing billions of dollars at the chip
industry a hundred billion by by one
estimate now on the eve of the Congress
um Joe Biden signed off on further
sanctions against China which restricted
the sale of the top end chips to China
but went much further than that and
restricted the sale by any company but
was using American tools to make their
chips now that's significant because the
Americans make most of the advanced
tools which in turn are used to make
chips so any company using American
tools is now barred from selling those
Advanced chips to China so that's that's
that's a pretty significant blow and of
course there are signs that China's
efforts its domestic efforts to build a
chip industry are themselves floundering
a bit The anti-corruption Campaign which
has been a signature uh policy of Xi
Jinping has recently targeted the chip
industry because there's a feeling that
a lot of this money is being stolen or
misappropriated or otherwise
disappearing and a number of Executives
in the chip industry have been arrested
or are under investigation including the
information Minister himself so on the
chip front it's becoming more intense
this chip wore and I would say pretty
worrying for Xi Jinping
and can you explain to our viewers what
these chips are used for and why they're
so important to China
well they use for everything Kate all I
mean you name it from a mobile phones to
laptops other consumer electronics all
the way through to Advanced weapon
systems aircraft
um these are indispensable to the the
advanced technological technological
economy and of course with China having
Grand Ambitions to lead the world in in
new futuristic Technologies IR for
instance robotics Advanced chips are
absolutely essential to this these are
the essential building blocks of the
advanced economy and really whoever can
Master the chip technology
um will take a lead in numerous other
Technologies in turn so when we look at
the technological competition that's
developing between the West between the
United States in particular and China
access to chips and the ability to build
a world-class chip industry are absolute
essential
Kerry what message is the United States
trying to send here they seem to have
just landed some of the most stringent
export controls in decades
what message I think we don't like you
we wish you weren't around but you're
not going to disappear so we just have
to carry on manually manageably
irritating each other and just deal with
it I mean um it kind of makes sense that
you are protective of what advantages
you still have you know if you think of
The Narrative of the last 40 50 years a
lot of things that China wasn't expected
it will be able to do in manufacturing
and Technology I mean a lot of those
things now it can do
um and so I suppose if you kind of since
2016-17 had a very different
relationship between particularly the
United States and China you are gonna
for both sides be really Keen to have
pretty deep boundaries between each
other and to look after your advantages
and to do something about your
disadvantages now on the disadvantage
Dominion's spoken well about the you
know the the semiconductors issue I mean
and on the disadvantages and what to do
about that for China
the big speech that Xi Jinping made at
the beginning of the Congress on the
16th of October uh had a lot in it about
making an innovation Nation huge
interest interests and increases in
education in technology training trying
to make world-class universities now not
the aspirations but the money that's
been put into that is huge some of it of
course will be misapprocreated but I
think the government's assumption in
Beijing is that they will be able to
decouple more quickly if they just put
loads of loads of money in technology
education and research and development
that's a big assumption because you can
waste an awful lot of money in that area
but I think that's what they're going to
try and do and they'll probably have
some successes just finding on
semiconductors
um that's such a politicized area now
they have a long-term disadvantages
always like they're five years behind so
I think America's um with Taiwan is the
biggest you know kind of manufacturer of
these things uh is kind of probably wise
to be very very protected with this
sector whether China will ever be able
to make up that technology you know kind
of Gap well who knows but they're doing
their best to do so it wouldn't be easy
but they're trying to
United position between Republicans and
Democrats in the states carry it seems
like Joe Biden has taken former
president Donald Trump's Playbook using
export controls and severe restrictions
like this
yeah I mean I think the consensus is
that the Democrats and the Republicans
this is probably one of the few issues
they agree on you know they have a
common enemy
um I but the issue is that there's many
things where they're just gonna have to
work with China I mean and that's a
problem for all of us I mean I mean you
know politically and diplomatically you
saw the big fight the kind of Manchester
Constitution consulate you know this
week in Britain and well do we expel
diplomats for expelled diplomats and
excellent escalates things and you have
to carry on talking to you know a major
partner like China this is gonna need
constant management this relationship
it's not going to go away we're just
going to have to live with it and I
think a lot of the language and American
politicians and British politicians is
this sort of magic fairy that you know
oh if we do this we're going to end up
with something better no this is just
going to need constant management there
is no ideal outcome to this I can't see
not for the next few decades anyway
in can China drastically create these
chips what do you make of Carrie's point
that they'll be doing everything they
can to become self-reliant and domestic
producers
they'll certainly be trying very hard
and they're certainly throwing an awful
lot of money at it but they are by some
estimates a few years possibly even a
couple of decades behind on chip
technology and of course that it's it's
not the target they're looking to catch
up with is not standing still they're
racing ahead you have billions being put
into the industry in the States you have
the the Taiwanese who lead the world in
in advanced chip production some nine
out of ten of the most advanced chips
are made in Taiwan they're also throwing
billions at building new fabrication
plants and indeed in Taiwan they see it
very much as a form of Defense having
all those factories those those Fabs
present on the island now Xi Jinping
clearly sees this as an issue of
National Security it's a it's it's a
fundamental issue there's an awful lot
of skullduggery going on as well in
terms of cyber attacks in terms of
poaching Talent from other parts of the
world to work in in on in on Chinese
chip companies so there's a lot going on
under the table above the table it's a
priority for China to catch up on chips
but it's it's not going to be easy
because it is a moving Target
Terry what does the US's latest movement
chips
for the Chinese economy but also for the
US economy
well I miss obviously an extra element
in a really difficult situation now the
bigger things the Chinese economy are a
housing market that's always been a
problem for 15 years and I've been aware
that property bubble issues and
overvaluation these things have been
worried about in the Chinese property
sector but this time it seems the price
is really falling and there's a huge
issue with uh you know kind of
oversupply I mean this is not um this is
a massive economic problem for China if
it does uh break you've also got the
continuing impact of covid-19
implementation of zero covered policies
Xi Jinping on Sunday said that will
continue
um so you know that's having a big
impact on Supply chains and factories
sometimes being closed whole areas being
closed off and then finally you've got
the global situation which looks really
difficult Russia's invasion of Ukraine
the impact that in Europe inflation I
mean these are a real shocking group of
things to you know anyone to deal with I
think China has not released its
statistics about its assessment of what
the next year is going to be in terms of
growth
um or other areas that it's aspiring to
shows a great nervousness at the new
leadership that will appear in Beijing
at the Congress in the next few days
um this is what they're going to have to
spend their whole time dealing with as
we go forward at least well at least for
the next year and probably longer
Carrie you spoke about the Party
Conference in one of your earlier
answers which has started this week can
you give us the latest on what's
happened and what to expect over the
next couple of days
yeah I mean this is a very predictable
event because China is deep into
predictability at the moment and I think
that is because the rest of the world is
very very unpredictable it's kind of
reversed for what it was maybe in the
past so I think it's most likely it's
using ping will continue in his role I
mean it would be very weird if he didn't
if all the messaging uh the long speech
he made didn't offer any policy
Innovation uh or kind of new
developments it's a commitment to the
things that the government already
committed to and it looks like the
people being talked of as fellow members
of the pilot Bureau they're currently
seven members uh those who might join
um you know kind of look like they are
very technocratic no one there looks
like a potential successor so very very
very cautious very predictable and I
think probably very very focused on the
fact the country is facing the most
significant problems economically that
it's probably faced for for decades
this latest trip were and contributes to
the narrative that China and the US are
decoupling and arguably the West more
General generally is decoupling from
China as well what are you making of all
this and what does it mean for the rest
of the world
I think decoupling is something which
both sides have been it's often
portrayed as a policy of the US or of
the west but you could argue that
decoupling began in China I mean
self-reliance particularly on technology
has been a mantra of Xi Jinping so for
both economies it is a priority to to
decouple to move their economies apart
and inevitably I think that's going to
have a huge impact on businesses
everywhere because it it becomes more
difficult to organize everything from
Supply chains to investment to other
decisions about the way that you deal
with China economically and China in
business terms I mean I think just to go
back to the the Congress to me one of
the the biggest events this week was a
non-event and this was the failure to
publish economic statistics on Tuesday
which which Kerry mentioned this
included the quarterly GDP P figures and
the assumption is that they're bad and
that's why they didn't want to bring
them out and of course one of the
reasons they're bad is because of the
zero covid policy of Xi Jinping and it
would have looked rather bizarre a day
after he stood up to talk about how zero
covid was the people's War if you then
issued statistics which showed the
collateral damage being caused by the
people's War but the economic challenges
are huge and I think to go back to the
issue of decoupling when companies or
countries start to look at their policy
towards China they're increasingly
talking about you know China Supply
chains was it was always seen as as
where is it cheap to make stuff now it's
about where is it resilient to make
stuff and and that works against China
and I think a lot of the economic
decisions that are being made in
boardrooms or among countries around the
world
um have to take account of this
increased decoupling which as I say is a
policy of both sides
Carrie and Anne thanks for joining me
if you enjoy spectator TV then why not
subscribe to the magazine go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
and try one month of the magazine in
print and online for free
we're just a few weeks away from the U.S
midterm elections Freddie gray writes in
this week's magazine that things might
not go as well as the Democrats hope to
explain he joins me now alongside
Stephanie Brown James co-founder of the
collective pack
Freddy you write in your piece for the
magazine this week that last year
President Biden was on a hot streak is
he still
well I think it was over the summer uh
certainly there was a little talk about
Joe Biden being on a hot streak and it
wasn't all uh wishful thinking on the
part of Democrats there was certainly a
good few uh moments good few events for
the Democrats that helped them in August
and September Joe Biden was perceived to
have had some legislative legislative
wins that was the passing of the
inflation reduction act and there was
also a student debt relief program that
certainly seemed to buy his support a
little bit in the polls and there was
also on the Republican side the big
event which was the overturning of Roe v
Wade which polls suggested alarmed a lot
of Independence and moderates and active
activated and Infused the Democratic
base however having spoken to uh quite a
few pollsters and Republicans in the
last few days there is definitely a lot
of optimism on the Republican side now
and a bit of panic and concern on the
Democratic side because the latest
numbers are showing that the Blue Wave
to counter the Red Wave is perhaps not
as strong as a lot of Democrats hoped
we were now just mere weeks away from
the midterms what are you picking up on
yeah I would definitely agree you know
we see the polls continue to fluctuate
but at the same time that is somewhat of
what we're used to when it starts to get
this close you know we're about almost
20 days left from election day you start
to see the Panic really on both sides
especially on the side of the party that
is trying to maintain control and that
is the Democratic party
um but what we're seeing right now out
of Georgia we've seen strong early vote
numbers thus far from voters we're
seeing a lot of traction of people
talking about the importance of the
Senate and I think that is really where
a lot of the conversation has taken
place
um but at the end of the day it's going
to matter on which party is able to turn
out their base and who can convince
Independents who can convince the
Suburban moms and women that they are
the party to not only help them now but
to help progress
um their Futures forward and so there's
a lot to see left on the horizon here
before election day Freddie what do you
think the biggest uphill battle is for
the Republican party at this point is it
the overturn of Roe v Wade and the
debate that's created in the Republican
party or is something else going on
I think Democrats think uh that the big
issues for Republicans the big issue of
Republicans is Roe v Wade and also Trump
and uh January 6th those are the issues
uh that hurt Republicans most in the
minds of swayable Voters uh however I
think the thing to set against that and
the real thing that's working in favor
of the Republicans have known is the
economy and inflation which Biden hoped
was going down he took rather a large
gamble that it would go down but it in
fact has not gone down and the inflation
reduction act has not uh yet at any rate
done anything to reduce inflation in
America so and and in fact Biden has
been slightly tone deaf and his
administration has been slightly tone
deaf in the way they've talked about
inflation only last weekend Biden eating
yet another ice cream uh said that he
thought the economy was strong as hell
now you could make that case but I don't
think a lot of Americans particularly
lower middle class Americans are feeling
that economy is strong as hell at the
moment and Stephanie I want to ask you
the same question from the other side
what is the biggest uphill battle for
the Democrats going into these midterm
elections and also what would you say is
their strength
I definitely agree that inflation
continues to be a problem the cost of
goods here is out of control but it's
also out of control across the entire
globe and so inflation the lack of
employment Rising is an issue if you
look at I think virtually any Republican
ad that's on TV they're talking about
the high crime numbers they are placing
that squarely as a responsibility of
Democrats as to why we have uh this this
violent rise in crime and so those are
definitely some uphill battles that the
Democrats are going to have to face
um and and also you know the Democrats
have not always been the best at
communicating their messages clearly
um in a in a forceful way and so um to
be able to to get out there you know we
know that President Obama is now about
to hit the campaign Trail he's going to
Wisconsin uh Michigan you know that's
going to be an important bump
um but if there's not this course from
Democrats across the country singing the
same hymn it's going to to continue to
be an uphill battle for them to turn out
not only their base and strong numbers
but again these Independents who are so
crucial to this year's election
Freddie President Obama will be a very
familiar face uh to Americans but there
are some less familiar faces especially
in these Senate races
um of course the results is what
everybody's going to be looking towards
but there's some really wacky Senate
races going on at the moment can you
talk us through a couple of them
yes I think uh these midterms will
possibly be remembered not for the
results so much as uh the sort of
craziness of some of the races uh one
particularly colorful character is
Herschel Walker who's running for the
senate in Georgia uh he is a legendary
American football running back uh
legendary in Georgia and he has had an
extremely colorful life to put it mildly
and he struggled with mental health
problems uh he's had a very checkered
history in his relationships and it
recently emerged all allegations emerged
that he paid a woman 700 for an abortion
which is uh lends him to charges of
hypocrisy because he's a very fervent
Evangelical and pro-lifer
um he's just one colorful character if
you go to Pennsylvania the other
colorful character that is in the news a
lot is John fetterman who is uh he's I
put it in my pieces the New York times's
idea of a working-class guy because he
wears hoodies
out of shorts and has tattoos and a lot
of people think that makes him have
popular appeal however his opinions I
think it would be fair to say are to the
left of the American mainstream uh and
the big Saga over his race has been that
he had a stroke in May which is
obviously horrible and no one uh wants
to say anything unkind about that
however there are questions about
whether he will be able to do the job he
recently did an interview in which he
had to use a screen to answer the
questions
a lot of the people who raise concerns
about that were dismissed as ableist
um I'm not sure what voters in
Pennsylvania will think of it at the
moment that race looks very tight
because vitamin himself is against a
fairly wacky character who's a celebrity
doctor called Mehmet Oz uh who's a sort
of used to be a kind of snake oil
salesman on TV but is nonetheless very
famous and a good televisual performer
and I think that's an interesting
reflection on where American politics is
going that televisual appeal uh is
really really the dominant theme now in
these sorts of races Stephanie Freddie
mentions there a few of the Trump air
Republicans that have been brought into
the party over the past few years are
these the sorts of candidates that worry
the Democrats or are they actually
delighted to go up against them because
they think their prospects are better
I think it's a little bit of both we saw
just a few months back that there were
some criticisms that Democrats were
actually helping
um in the primary period some candidates
on the Republican side to be successful
because they were more of these unsavory
untenable characters who are extremely
far right very much more far right than
than what the American people seem to be
with just a little bit more moderate
um and not as extreme and so
um you know I think at the end of the
day it's a it's a distraction I don't
think it's good for America politics at
all when you have individuals who don't
have strong policy platforms that that
they can stand on to say how they're
going to actually make things better
they don't have the experience to be
able to to say how they're going to pass
legislation and be bipartisan in their
approach and so you know I don't think
it actually bodes well for any of us
um and it doesn't
um it doesn't I think encourage a next
generation of young people who are
concerned about our democracy who want
to get into politics because it almost
doesn't seem serious anymore when you
have characters like Herschel Walker in
the race and so you know I just hope
that the American people can stay firmly
focused on the issues and and who are
those candidates whether they're
Republican Or democrats who can actually
um talk about policies in a way
um that makes it seem like they can
actually do something once they get to
Washington now I'm not going to be
unkind and ask either of you to give me
a prediction uh but Stephanie I'm right
in thinking that you actually called the
ticket of Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
quite early on didn't you
yeah I did
um I said I think it was January of that
year
um that I I just thought that the the
ideal matchup was Joe Biden because of
his experience
um his time
um in Congress and being able to be a
person that reached across the aisles
quite often and someone who was very
familiar with all factors of fascists of
the community I thought that he was a
strong candidate for president and that
now Vice President Kamala Harris
um with her experience as a prosecutor
as an attorney general
um of the largest Judicial System
um in the country I thought that she had
the Vigor and the youth and also as a
South Asian African-American woman that
she would be a strong Counterpoint and
here we are and I still believe that
wasn't I still believe that they're
they're a strong ticket I think
um you know they are they are working
well together
um considering all the headwinds they
face
um in their current positions this is
the question I wanted to get to for you
Stephanie what states do you think that
these two people now President and Vice
President formerly candidates when when
you were um
forecasting I suppose what was going to
happen
um to what state do you think they've
put the Democratic party in going into
these midterms
yeah I think you know honestly the way
politics is going now you know they say
all politics is local I think that is
extremely true and we're seeing that you
know you have a lot of candidates that
aren't necessarily excited about having
um Washington come into their states you
know they they are looking forward to
President Obama coming if possible some
folks are looking forward to President
Biden but I think most people just want
to run their own races
um now they need to support money of the
establishment to help do that
um but I think when it comes down to
standing on policies and standing on
areas where there have been traction the
Democrats and President Biden and vice
president Harris are trying to move the
needle on inflation they are trying to
move the needle when it comes to student
loan reform they're trying to move the
needle when it comes to how marijuana
laws are enforced in this country and so
they are working to make progress and
have made progress and I think if the
Democratic candidates can focus on those
progress areas
um opposed to some of the more personal
elements of the president and vice
president I think that they will be
successful but also still run their own
races and talk about the issues that
their constituents most care about and
Freddie what state do you think the
Democratic party is in going into these
midterms and the Republican party as
well
I think both parties like all
established parties all over the
developed world are facing huge problems
um I do think the Democrats have not
shown a very good grip of reality
particularly in regards to the economy
and I do think the Republicans have an
issue with trumpism which is that they
don't know if it's their future or not
and so they're torn between
these uh very eccentric trumpy
characters and uh they're all
traditional Bush era party that doesn't
really appeal to people so much so I
think both have real problems unlike
Stephanie I have a very mixed actually
bad record of predicting things but I am
going to put a prediction uh out there
right now and say that Republicans will
win the house I think that's fairly a
fairly safe bet probably quite easily
and I'm also going to say that
Republicans going to win the Senate uh
very narrowly wow that's a bold
prediction
well Freddie will uh know if you're
right or wrong in a few weeks time for
now Freddie and Stephanie thanks so much
for joining me
now to birds spectator contributor Matt
Ridley writes in this week's magazine
that a new strain of bird flu could wipe
out Britain's avian Wildlife to discuss
Matt joins me now
Matt thank you so much for joining
spectator TV in the magazine this week
you write about a new lethal strain of
bird flu can you give us a sense of the
scale and of the spread of this pandemic
as you call it
yeah this is the worst outbreak of Avian
Influenza in wild birds we've ever seen
um it's been particularly bad in the UK
this last summer and indeed the previous
winter in certain species and what's and
it's now bad in America as well it seems
to have come from Asia and it's killing
um in some cases thousands of uh
seabirds in particular and it's doing it
pretty indiscriminately in other words
it doesn't seem like any bird species
are immune you know buzzards are getting
it Pelicans are getting it plovers are
getting it seabirds are getting it
um anything that breeds in dense
colonies or anything that eats dead
birds so things like skewers and
buzzards and crows are suffering as well
so there's clearly something pretty
drastic happening in the bird world at
the moment worldwide
really worrying stuff do we have any
idea what led to this new lethal strain
we have some idea but I don't think we
know entirely what's going on
um they've been Avian Influenza is found
in wild birds it's it's been endemic in
wild birds forever and from time to time
poultry flocks have caught it from wild
birds and there have been outbreaks
which have been
um sometimes very disastrous there was a
particularly bad strain got into poultry
in 1996 called h5n1 this seems to be a
descendant of that but I what it looks
like is it's a descendant that's been in
domestic birds and has now bounced back
into wild birds so instead of this being
something that poultry are catching from
wild birds it's something wild birds are
catching from poultry
and is this something exclusively
affecting birds or mammals at risk as
well
this form of Avian Influenza in fact
most original strains of influenza
um are bird diseases
um but obviously mammals do get
influenza human beings get influenza
they probably got it from Birds
originally via pigs in our case probably
but so it is possible for this to
transmit to mammals people have caught
these new strains of influenza in Hong
Kong in 1997 about 18 people caught it
and six of them died since then there
have been very few cases but have been a
couple of cases this year what has not
been seen in mammals so far is chains of
transmission so
if one person gets it they don't pass it
on to anyone else yet the virus is not
well designed to infect mammals it's
much better designed at infecting Birds
but there is concern that that could
change
and what is the level of that concern
obviously what's happening to the bird
population is worrying in and of itself
but at what point do we start to
seriously consider the possibility of
human infection that could be
transmitted to other humans
well some setting in which
um the virus was under strong selective
evolutionary pressure to spread among
mammals is what we're sort of looking at
and worried about so for example pigs
feeding with ducks consistently for
years and years and years and catching
this thing and eventually the virus
saying well I'm going to cut out the
middle man I'm just going to go from
Peak to Peak I'm not going to go back
into a burden and out again that's
probably what we're talking about but
there was a series of experiments done
10 years ago in Rotterdam and in
Wisconsin
um which were called the gain of
function experiments which were
addressing exactly this question they
were essentially taking the virus and
deliberately mutating it this is an h5n1
avian influenza virus deliberately
mutating it and seeing whether it
infected ferrets so well that the ferret
could then infect another ferret at the
other end of the room without touching
it
in other words Airborne transmission now
those experiments became very
controversial because people said why
are we doing the very experiment we're
worried about why are we trying to
persuade this virus to turn into a
mammal Airborne virus and so there was
actually that led to a major debate
about how danger how wish what sort of
experience we should do with such
dangerous viruses
um uh and by the way those two
experiments were done under very careful
conditions and The Regulators knew about
them it wasn't they weren't Rogue
experiments or anything like that but
they did lead to this debate and that
debate resulted in a moratorium
on similar experiments at least on the
funding of them in the U.S now during
that moratorium funding found its way to
Wuhan in China to do similar experiments
on coronaviruses whether as a direct
result of the moratorium or not we can't
be clear so this does relate back to the
whole story of the human pandemic of
covid
were there any findings from those
experiments with the ferrets before they
were ended
yes the the the general conclusion of
those ferret experiments was that it
wouldn't take much
in terms of mutations for Avian
Influenza to turn into mammalian
influenza
um that that there was only three or
four steps away from doing so it just
wasn't usually under much selective
pressure to do so so
um the experiments were concerning in
that sense and did therefore give us
information we needed to know
Matt let me ask you what's happening on
farms and the impact on Farmers about
the repercussions of this new lethal
strain of bird flu there have been some
reports saying that farmers could see a
shortage of turkeys this Christmas for
example
well obviously it's a very distressing
and worrying time for poultry Farmers as
I say this disease seems to have sort of
got going in poultry Farms it's ideally
suited to infecting them and although
the original h5n1 strain was quite
successfully suppressed with vaccines
and other measures in China for a while
it does seem to have opened the door for
other stronger variants to then appear
in farms so there are outbreaks
occurring in the UK in chicken farms and
other poultry facilities particularly in
the east of England in Norfolk and
Suffolk and elsewhere
and that is resulting in the slaughter
of of flocks which obviously does lead
to fewer chickens on the market and so
on so I think it it is not impossible
that we will see
turkey shortages I mean you know if you
are keeping free-range turkeys
um as I do on my farm for example you
have to you are now saying well perhaps
they should be indoors from now till
Christmas well that's not very nice for
the turkeys
um uh that they have to be locked up for
a couple of months
um
uh so you know there are there's there's
a balance of concerns between
um Animal Welfare uh considerations and
uh biosafety considerations that that
farmers are having to to to consider and
Matt last question to you given the
point you made earlier about how this
virus is most likely to spread when
birds and even sometimes mammals are
closely packed together is this new
lethal strain going to raise questions
again perhaps reignite the discussion
around intensive battery farming
well I think it it does look like this
particularly nasty strain of Avian
Influenza started in uh intense domestic
flocks and that's why it's so lethal why
it's so virulent because
um basically in in wild birds you don't
want to be too virulent because you want
the birds to remain healthy enough to
infect each other
um you don't have to worry about that so
much if they're all crammed together so
it looks like that might be the source
of the of the problem so that would
imply that we've got to somehow row back
on the intensity of our of our chicken
rearing
but on the other side of the equation
you can say that the safest flux the
ones that are not going to catch this
are the ones that are hermetically
sealed away from wild birds and so we're
not going to get the the the vectors in
the wild bird population visiting them
and therefore the ones most at risk are
the free range flocks that are out in
fields for part of the day and where a
jackdaw might come along to feed on the
food that's been spread out for the
chickens having just fed on a dead
um Goose that's died on a pond nearby so
there's a slight
Paradox here that in some senses it's
the it's the most intensive ones that
that might be safest because you can
keep viruses out so I don't quite know
where this debate will take us
well we'll be back to you Matt to give
us some updates if and when they're
available thanks so much for joining
spectator TV
and finally I'm sure you've seen the
videos the group just stop oil is
staging some very provocative stunts
across the UK what does the group want
and do they think their stunts are
working I'm joined Now by Emma Brown a
spokesperson for just stop oil
Emma thanks for joining me on spectator
TV so you are a member of just stop oil
which has been in the news a lot
recently given some of its disruptive
protesting what is your end goal
and so we have one really simple demand
and it's a demand that we have in common
with the um the World Bank with the UN
and with the International Energy agency
and that is the UK government cannot
license any more fossil fuel projects in
the UK
um we know that this is completely
incompatible
um with us and our children surviving
the next few decades so
um that is what we are demanding just
that the UK government make a meaningful
statement on that and immediately hold
the 100 new licenses that they're
currently proposing is there a reason
that you've chosen that immediate
deadline as opposed to say in a year
from now given the energy crisis that
the world is facing because of Russia's
against aggression against Ukraine we're
already talking about blackouts in the
UK this winter for example is this the
right time to be making this immediate
demand
it is the right time um because we know
um from the uh intergovernmental panel
on climate change that was actually in
the UK last year that if we continue
exploring for oil and gas and locking
ourselves into a fossil fuel dependent
future what excuse do we have to tell
other countries not to do the same and
that is leading us down to like
catastrophic climate collapse within our
lifetimes so it is absolutely the right
time I also think it's a huge
opportunity for us
um in a way because what is more energy
secure what then homegrown energy in the
form of renewable energy it's also so
much quicker to implement than new oil
and gas Fields these could take upwards
of 5 10 15 even 20 years to come online
so they'll do absolutely nothing to
lower prices and they'll do absolutely
nothing to increase energy security
because what we're asking for um is that
there's no new licensing of fossil fuels
so we're not asking to to turn the tap
off now we're not asking to close our
existing Fields where we're asking for
an eight-year transition which is plenty
of time you know we really need if we
care about our kids if we care about
having enough food to eat enough water
you know not dying in catastrophic
climate collapse then then we really
need to be ambitious and we really need
to be um
having almost a war-like effort to
increase our renewable capacity that
eight year timeline that you lay out uh
might if we were very ambitious get some
nuclear power plants online would you
agree with turning to nuclear as a
source of renewable energy
um I mean the only problem well the main
problem I have with nuclear energy is
obviously we have a impacts with nuclear
waste
um but the campaign is specifically
targeting the the new licenses of oil
and gas because we know that that is
driving the catastrophic climate
collapse so it at this point
unfortunately with the government we
have
they're not even looking into Solutions
they're fueling part of the problem
um one major concern as well in is in
terms of the time frames that we have
like we could you know invest heavily in
renewable energy but these things take a
long time to create whereas the biggest
solar farm in the UK was built in six
weeks and the biggest wind firm we built
in six months so we know that these
These are the kind of quick solutions
that we need and we also need to be
driving down um energy demand in the
form of like my nan used to say don't
heat the sky like there's no point
producing energy that just goes out the
window we need Mass insulation
um and good public transport and things
like that as well and so it's all part
of the mix can you tell me a little
about a little bit about how just stop
oil is run
um does the organization have a board
that has control
um over what its members are supposed to
to say and how they're supposed to act
so for example was it the organization
that decided to throw the tomato soup
over the van Gogh painting at the
National Gallery or was the was that an
individual decision taken by the people
who did it under the brand of just stop
oil
um it's a bit of a mixture of both so um
we have like a um like more of a
strategic team that look at like the
whole kind of strategy and the whole
um direction that we're going in but we
also have an actions team that planned
the actions
um and they also like speak to
individuals and see what they would want
to do if it was more of a media grabbing
attention or if it's more of a strategic
disruption
um
um action so it's not like we have some
like specific figures that are like
controlling everything like I know one
of the action planners and they're like
pretty young person from Glasgow so
um and I know a couple of the people
that actually did the action at the Van
Gogh
um and they also would have had a an
input into if that's what they wanted to
do and so it's a bit of a mixture there
is like a kind of strategy but we do get
a say in what we're doing and we're not
just sort of told what to do sure so but
so then just to be clear the the action
at the National Gallery that was uh that
was not Rogue individuals throwing the
tomato sauce that was a decision from
just stop oil to to perform that
yeah it would have been a decision by
like well it would have been an idea by
the actions team and they would have
like
um spoken to people and asked if they
wanted to do that action and it would
have been one of like
um like a group of actions that we were
thinking about and we would have like
picked one and if that was something
that people wanted to do I'm curious
because it's a point of Pride for a lot
of people in the UK that the National
Gallery is free that it gives access to
people of all different incomes and
backgrounds to access world-class art
and one of the arguments that people
sometimes use about charging is that it
would limit the access that people would
have for for those who can't pay are you
worried that your actions might lead to
a charging system to protect the art
that would then remove access to people
who were otherwise not able to pay
um I I don't think that's that's on the
cards um you know the the painting was
put back on display later that day it
was basically just wiped off with a bit
of kitchen roll
um I don't think the National Gallery
have plans to introduce charging because
I mean that wouldn't actually
um quell any protest anyway because it
would just be the cost of an entry
ticket to get in so I don't think that
that's that's really a concern I think
what's a huge concern is the fact that
we're not going to have
you know people around to to see these
amazing works of art like Humanity has
such an amazing history of creativity
Ingenuity working together to solve
problems but at the moment the people
that were allowing to make these
decisions for us are pretty criminally
incompetent and as we've seen the 40
degree heat waves in the UK
as we've seen like the catastrophic
effects of of global heating across the
world like are we really gonna leave
these critical years in terms of climate
tipping points up to these incompetent
people that's the question I'd ask your
listeners some of your fellow protesters
have been suggesting that vandalism is
an appropriate tool of protest do you
agree
I think that we've been like well people
have been trying to to raise this in the
agenda for the last 40 years
um
I think
sometimes we're asking the wrong
question
because what is more vandalism than
destroying the very like basic things
that we need to survive as people you
know destroying our air quality
destroying the the natural conditions
that allow us to have food to eat you
know um it's even if you just look up
when is the world going to run out of of
drinking water
um estimates are like Global shortages
of Water by 2040 if if we continue
wasting it at the rate that we're doing
now I I certainly don't want to put
words in your mouth so I just want to
clarify it it's it sounds like you're
suggesting that certain levels of
vandalism are okay because you believe
there's a bigger picture of vandalism
taking place is that fair to say
yeah I would say that we get called Eco
vandals but I would say like what what
is more like who are the real Eco
vandals they're the ones literally
trashing
our our like the basic things that we
need to survive our life support systems
um so I would say at this point in time
knowing that we are dangerously close to
Melting permafrost which will release
massive amounts of methane knowing that
we're dangerously close to losing the
animals and rainforest and that
producing more
um you know more carbon emissions as
that Forest dies knowing how how close
we are to those those tipping points
um I think I think
um more disruptive and more um
outrageous actions and
I think gonna happen because how can we
expect our young people to just sit back
um as we adults just continue as if
nothing is happening not seeming to give
a can I ask crap about that can I ask
what what the organization's red line is
for vandalism
um how far would you extend that does
that apply to public buildings but also
private buildings would that applied to
people's homes would that would that Red
Line stop before anybody's physically
hurt uh to what extent does the
organization weigh up these decisions
and where's the organizations
organization's red line on vandalism
well at number one the organization is
just made up of like Ordinary People
um so it's not as though it's this like
huge kind of structure that has like you
know a like a whole policy on on
vandalism for example well it's made up
of conversations between Ordinary People
I'll rephrase I'll rephrase where is
your red line on vandalism where would
you tell yourself my red line my
complete red line is on non-violence
it's not hurting people that is my red
line I think that's really important but
I think that is where the line needs to
be drawn because I think it's you know
we're making decisions which are violent
the government is making decisions which
are violent because they those policies
are contributing to the deaths and
sufferings of people so for me uh in
terms of action on the climate my red
line is non-violent so not hurting
people well then let me ask you some of
your protesters blocked a fire engine
and an ambulance with blue lights on in
West London last week they were unable
to get through the traffic what would
your message to them be um presumably
that is taking human life into account
yeah so we do have a blue lights policy
so we will let ambulances and fire
engines through and and if they're
showing their lights then we will let
them through a couple of them decided to
turn around
um which was unfortunate but I think we
need to be like there's always a um like
a a difficulty because anything that we
do that is disruptive is is gonna cause
you know difficulties for people but
we're doing that in the face of a much
greater problem and we also need to be
focusing on outrage sometimes on the
causes of that like the causes of the
huge wait times for ambulances that are
causing people to die of heart attacks
or I phoned an ambulance the other day
for a lady that had hit her head and it
took six and a half hours for an
ambulance to come and that's not because
of a few protesters blocking a road for
an hour that's because of like massive
massive cuts
um and underfunding of the NHS so so I
would argue with that and I know the
fire and the fire service they're
thinking of going on strike you know
which could cost human life but we've
got to think of the reasons why people
doing these disruptive things like
striking
um like doing disruptive protests like
we are and that is because there's a
greater issue of of
um Mass suffering you know like the the
fireworks service had the busiest day
that it had since the second world war
during the heat wave because of fires
caused by that heat wave due to the
climate crisis there is absolutely
they've been so underfunded
um that they're not going to be able to
cope with what's coming
it's important to bear that into into
about the strains on the NHS and the 7
million person waiting list on NHS
England Alone
um but last week in West London the blue
lights were on and they were that fire
engine and ambulance were blocked from
getting through I guess what I'm asking
is would you have any words to those
protesters given your own red lines or
their actions that you really think have
already taken place that were perhaps
slightly inappropriate and actually put
lives at risk
um
I don't to be honest I don't think
lives were you know but to be honest
it's terrible that we're having to cause
this disruption
did I mean it's unacceptable that we're
stopping people going about their daily
business
but you need to ask the we need to think
about why we're doing this you know why
teachers lawyers like um students
Vickers are sitting in a road being like
shouted at them by people or um causing
disruption to people none of us that
want to be causing disruption to people
but the fact of the matter is we've got
a criminally incompetent government that
are not willing to listen to the kind of
rational arguments that we've been
making for years the rational arguments
that their own advisors are making the
rational arguments that scientists are
making so that's why we're we are in
those positions let me ask you one more
question
um are you convinced that your actions
and your protests and the vandalism so
far are swaying hearts and Minds towards
your cause
so we don't need hearts and Minds like
we don't we don't care if we are
personally
um
hated no the cars I'm talking about the
cars the the cars of reducing around the
hills and oil consumption
but I mean I don't like we're actually
getting media attention you're talking
to me now you know unfortunately the
we've been protesting outside oil
terminals we've been doing that but
that's not we need to get this raised in
the in the agenda the political agenda
and raised in the Consciousness and the
fact that we've been doing like I've had
three interviews this morning and that
you're speaking to me and you're
allowing me to speak to your your
listeners is one sign that is working
very quickly on that I mean I'm I'm
delighted with climate action I think
the majority of the British population
are extremely worried about climate
collapse and the majority of the British
population do believe that the UK
government is not doing enough and we
just need that LinkedIn to to looking at
the policies you know the RS the reward
Society for the protection of birds are
coming out against the government's
policies so we are seeing that people
are concerned and I don't I don't see
that what we are doing is turning people
off being worried about climate collapse
because if we go away climate collapse
is not going to go away and people can
can do whatever they want to do about
that you know we've tried writing I've
written to my mp so many times it makes
absolutely no difference so I'd advise
your your listeners if they they hate
the tactics that we're using but they
are worried about climate collapse which
everyone should be
um then then by all means try those
things first and you'll see that they
don't work and then come and join us I'm
delighted to speak to you Emma I'm
finding this very interesting but I'm
not talking about swaying my heart or
mind or any other media interviewer is
harder mind I mean the people that you
are speaking to to spectator TV today
all of our audience do you think your
tactics and this conversation and what
you're saying is is convincing them
well this is the thing so immediately
what you what you see when you're
looking for like that that that
political change or that big radical
change that we need
um not a lot in you know to have some
kind of nice
um political world like just to
literally for our children to be able to
survive we know that we need radical
changes for that so so those aren't
going to happen by us you know
feeling really comfortable about
everything we're not just going to
really smoothly slide into that
different
um social and political reality where we
get action on the climate it is going to
cause tension and sometimes that
emotional connection is what's needed so
I would say you know like as you're
you're saying about your your listeners
on The Spectator podcast that we had
someone
um as I was sitting on a block actually
outside Downing Street come up to us and
say I'm sorry that I was pulling you off
the roads earlier because you were
disrupting me like an ordinary Londoner
but he said but I looked into why you're
doing it and now I totally agree and I
see why it's necessary and that's the
kind of shift that we need so obviously
at first there will be that like outrage
what what they're doing why are they
doing it but then once people look into
why once they see you the policies this
government are doing which are driving
us Into Climate collapse then if that
doesn't if knowing the facts doesn't
change your mind and I don't know what
does because I'm worried about my niece
like she's three years old and we're
facing water shortages before she's 18
we're facing crop failure next year that
is the thing we need to be outraged at
and if people can be outraged at us and
maybe that leads to some outrage into
the things that they should be outraged
at then I don't mind being hated I don't
mind being spatter whatever I just need
we just need action well I certainly
hope nobody would uh fit or suggest any
kind of violence towards you or the
protesters Emma thank you very much for
joining me
that's it for this week once again
thanks to Cana core genuity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes they will provide you with the
expertise you need to build up your
wealth and confidence visit can do
wealth.com for more information and
don't forget to subscribe to the
spectator's YouTube channel just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the Bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]